back to las vegas now the southwest
medical hospice care the sponsors of the
segment provide the right care at the
right time and with the right companion
my name is chantel crevello and i'm a
volunteer with southwest medical and
i've
been
volunteering for about seven months my
stepfather
was admitted into hospice care
it was my first experience with hospice
i kind of expected a lot of rigid rules
and regulations
and visiting hours and things like this
and it was quite the opposite i cooked
for him i brought it in
they even had a couch in the room i was
allowed to spend the night so because of
that experience
i really wanted to not only give back
but hopefully bring comfort to some
other patients i
love to put people at ease
so i like to go in there and just talk
to them see what their interests are
play with their pets
i had a patient that just wanted me to
help organize a couple of things things
of this nature
[Music]
so truly just being a friend to them and
learning about their
family what they like to do we can read
books together all kinds of things the
techkid program is a new concept a new
program and
it's just absolutely fantastic so
what we do is the volunteers call the
patients on thursdays and the idea is
that
they
we can get them anything they need
before the weekend rolls around and
they're they don't find themselves out
of supplies or medications the nurses
get busy the caretakers get busy so we
call them up on thursdays i say hello we
get to know each other after i call them
every week and
just basic supplies or and if they're
good they're good but they um sometimes
i'll call and they'll say well it must
be thursday
and then it's easy i call it in and the
nurses give them their supplies and
they're all tucked in for the weekend is
why we called it that program although
volunteering can be very fun and
uplifting sometimes there are serious
points to it and that's when i come home
my backyard is my
favorite place to be i've got everything
i love here i've got my two pets i have
a cat and a dog
so i'll sit here in the peaceful you
know serenity of this and
meditate
just i've got hummingbirds back here and
it's just the most peaceful environment
this is how i
really just decompress here because i
love doing this so much
i reach out to prospective volunteers
and
answer any questions and concerns
because i know there are
a lot of questions because i was in the
same position myself
and
so answer their questions tell them what
they're going to walk into
scheduling is you know a concern for
some people but
that's i think one of the best parts of
the whole program is
you get to see a snapshot of what the
job is going to entail
the hours and you can pick and choose
what days
so overall just let them know that it's
not only wonderful for the patients but
for themselves
it's it's the best thing i've ever done
and to be quite honest it's
something i wish i would have done a
long time ago but i cannot say enough
about being a volunteer
thank you to southwest medical hospice
care for sponsoring this segment call
or 702-671-1111 the website on your
screen for more information